alles hat ein ende darum soll es im
heutigen video geht dieses video hier
wird meinen kanal verändern meiner
meinung nach zum positiven erstmals als
es irgendjemand denkt juli und ich sind
immer noch zusammen also alles hat ein
ende ist nicht auf unsere beziehungen
bezogen allerdings würde ich sagen rede
ich erst mal ein bisschen jetzt gerade
dies mitte september 2018 das heißt
genau vor einem jahr habe ich meinen
bachelor gemacht an der uni zu der zeit
habe ich halt für die klausuren gelernt
ich habe meine arbeit geschrieben ich
habe noch ein praktikum nebenbei und ich
habe es trotzdem geschafft jeden tag
irgendwie noch ein youtube-video
rauszuhauen der hassel war zu der zeit
echt mehr als real zeit nach meinem
studienabschluss im september habe ich
noch immer weiter gehandelt habe nur
noch täglichen video gebracht doch dann
habe ich irgendwann gedacht hey ich hab
doch gestern stand gebracht heute kann
ich doch noch ein bisschen chillen und
ich bin halt immer entspannter geworden
und immer mehr in die komfortzone
reingerutscht solche sätze wie
beispielsweise hey ich habe heute noch
kein video auch alles gut klappt noch
gestern schon als hoch geladen war ja
morgen wieder eins hätte ich vor meinem
abschluss hätte ich das nie gesagt da
war ich wirklich jeden tag zugaben waren
neues video kommen ab zum praktikum ab
wieder einem bild erklärt arbeiter
menschen aber doch nach dem
studienabschluss habe ich echt immer
mehr gechillt und dann habe ich vor drei
monaten das projekt gestartet block 2 da
ging es darum dass ich meinen tag ganz
normal filme den morgen und den haben
dabei dazwischen passiert sein normales
video also eine challenge oder gaming
oder sonst irgendwas das war quasi
kompromiss zwischen blogs die sehr viele
leute wollten und meinen normalen videos
die auch selbst viele leute wollten ich
hatte also quasi einen ganzen tag zeit
um ein video zu drehen und den zweiten
tag hatte ich komplett zeit um das video
zu schneiden
den dritten tag wieder komplett
umzudrehen und weiter und so fort ich
hoffe ihr wisst was ich meine ich will
die idee ist allerdings auch gar nicht
schlecht reden weil es hat mir mega viel
spaß gemacht allerdings nicht dadurch
hat immer weiter mehr so kommt apple
geworden die komfortzone immer so
entspannter und irgendwann war es dann
halt so dass ich mir auch gesagt habe
ich hab doch vorgestern schon video
hochgeladen
dann kann ich das nächste erst in zwei
tagen bringen und dann war eine pause
von vier tagen dazwischen irgendwie
versteht mich nicht falsch ich will doch
auch nicht schlecht reden im körper und
ein selbst einfach mal eine pause zu
gönnen
ich selbst kann das glaube ich besser
sagen halt jeder andere weil ich selbst
ganz kurz vor einem burn out stand und
herzprobleme hatte weil ich zu viel
stress hat und zu wenig die penta habe
zu einer gewissen zeit in meinem leben
allerdings ist es mir jetzt gerade
aufgefallen als ich nach ibiza geflogen
bin vor zwei wochen also ich war da
gerade im urlaub und da habe ich einfach
gar kein video produziert früher war es
so helga durch erst in zwei wochen
urlaub für zwei wochen das heißt ab
jetzt produzieren jeden tag drei videos
machen damit wären nur im urlaub videos
vorproduziert kommen aber auf ibiza ich
weiß die mich jetzt einfach nicht
gejuckt ich hatte mir halt so gesagt
kommen auf gut glück seid dahin nur
filmstar es das da hoch und dann ließ
der zufall wollte natürlich kommen auch
dies am ersten tag direkt beim bloggen
kamera kaputt gegangen ist halb ins meer
gefallen
am zweiten tag iphone gefallen iphone
schrotti es gab einst mehr drin weil es
bei apple bei der reparatur schwieriges
wort und dann kamen die absolute höhe
meine damen und herren den vierten tag
auf die bezahlt haben ein heftiges
unwetter und der blitz ist bei uns das
appartement eingeschlagen und der
komplette strom war weg und trotzdem ein
kurzer ausschnitt
da wo der ivica strandurlaub dann ganz
schnell zusammen niagara falls trip
diese ganze situation hat mir dann auf
jeden fall zu denken gegeben weil was
anderes konnte ich auch nicht machen das
war eine schrott oben zu kommen ich habe
dann einfach mal darüber nachgedacht zu
ok was mach ich jetzt egal eigentlich
hab nichts vorproduziert ich bin seit
meinem bachelor einfach nur noch viel
entspannter geworden für chilliger
geworden ich muss irgendwas an meinem
leben ändern mit fehlt dieses kassels
jeden tag irgendwie was machen irgendwas
kreieren was weiß ich auch wenn es nur
beschissene scheiß videos für youtube
sind meine produktivitäts leistung ist
einfach von luca 120 prozent als ich
mein studium hat sie auf mittlerweile 30
prozent kontinuierlich immer weiter
runter gegangen und das macht das macht
mich krank einfach deswegen meine damen
und herren um auf die titel zu sprechen
zu kommen und diesem video endlich ein
ende zu geben alles hat ein ende ich
werde hier mit block 2 beenden
es tut mir leid es werden trotzdem noch
ab und zu blogs kommen allerdings nicht
primär und nur auf meinem kanal ich
setze mir nämlich heute mit dem heutigen
tage das ziel jeden tag und 18 uhr bei
der damen und herren davy wieder täglich
ein video rauszuhauen
ihr kennt mal zeitmanagement vielleicht
wird s mal 17 uhr
vielleicht wird's noch mal 21 uhr aber
auf jeden fall versuche ich derjenige
und bitte leute falls jetzt mal nicht
schafft von tag ein video hochzuladen
hated mich überall auf twitter instagram
und am letzten video macht mich einfach
fällig sodass sich viele user beim
nächsten tag du musst wieder was von
allerdings meine damen und herren möchte
ich auch sagen dass qualität immer noch
über qualität steht also ich habe als
ich noch zwei angefangen habe und nicht
wirklich den ganzen tag zeit hatte für
ein video war das immer so 10 15 minuten
lang die videos leicht jetzt täglich
hochladen will werden die videos er so
vier bis acht minuten aber dann dafür
immer täglich ein neues frisches thema
und eine neue video idee und dann halt
einfach kurz prägnant knapp alles lustig
locker flockig keine ahnung
last leichter wenn jetzt feiert hey
genug jetzt ihr schnäppchen kommentare
es soll einfach so ein bisschen werde
wie früher also täglich ein video und
ich gebe keinen finger auf irgendwie
zehn minuten und mache einfach das
worauf ich bock habe und mal clever bord
akinator fordern ein horror game sich
überhaupt mit mir neues format mit max
überlegt was wöchentlich kommen soll ich
habe mir die zahlen nur ein ablaufplan
angelegt
das hätte jetzt so blöd an aber ich
meinem ein halter ablaufplan sei einfach
so aus da hat man einfach nicht gern
reingeguckt zwei neue artwork plan ist
es mit farben und mit sonderstatus
checklisten allen möglichen also da will
man einfach lieber reingucken ich habe
mein aufnahme ist immer hinten wo ich
meine videos demnächst aufnehmen werde
habe ich komplett alles ausgemistet neu
gemacht gemacht weil ich glaube wenn man
produktiv und kreativ sein will dann
muss das auch in einer umgebung
stattfinden die einem jahr weiß ich
nicht die die einem gegen die
gefälschten ablaufplan oder sei es eine
aufnahme zimmern aber um dass wir
endlich zu beenden meine lieben freudig
lager wieder viel zu lange um in die es
einfach aufgefallen dass ich seit dem
bachelor studienabschluss immer weiter
in den start gegangen bin und deswegen
will ich jetzt wieder hoch und den hass
im ort gehen ab jetzt jeden tag von 1800
neues video also hey schreibt mir die
kommentare auf was ihr bock hätte etwas
ich hochlagen soll und sonst sehen wir
uns morgen um 18 uhr in und neuen video
habe ali k
[Musik]